bella a tutti ragazzi è venuto a questo
nuovo vinto io sono poi j
e oggi siamo su un videogame miglior
chiamato in sanitade o sanità cielo
italianizzandolo la peggio modo
chiameremo in sanità né allora
innanzitutto non vedo una mezza costa
romana beh comunque sia devo accendere
la luce perfetta adesso ti vede
benissimo allora violenti così ati
tantissimi questo gioco che è fatta
dagli stessi creatori di pesa delo che
non ho continuato perché non mi sembrava
granché dal continuo speriamo che questo
lo sia
vabbè allora iniziarono una partita voce
prenderà todos e un progresso no logo
enter qua racconti noir 5 anno se
pasaran delle a morte da mina e sposa
cromia mantoux como cortes sì ma se
sparisce sono né copi luca soft
allora ragazzi sono fermati con la
macchina e non so che poi un parcheggio
questo parcheggio è sanatorio refugio do
ios google traduttore quando serve cioè
il cellulare lontano
vabbè il rifugio la mia ignoranza in
materia a portoghese e
è una cosa pazzesca per un importo
ragazze non entriamo qui dentro
sanatorio penso voglia dire manicomio
sono quasi convinto tra l'altro cos'è
questa che i ragazzi trovato la chiave
era in fondo gli mette in fondo al
parcheggio mi son dovuto rifare tutto il
parcheggio perché poi sto deficiente non
corre e va bene non c'erano chiavi in
fondo il parcheggio non chiedetemi
perché non lo voglio neanche sapere va
beh siamo entrati non leggo perché tanto
non ci capiscono mazzo siamo entrati in
un post che mirabilandia messo a
confronto è triste va bene ragazzi ci
siamo
non so bene chi è stato
chi è che apposito chi è che chi è chi
ti ha dato il permesso di tossire che
succede ragazzi ok sto andando che cazzo
è un errore di gioco cosa ci vedo io
male raga che sta succedendo perché
quella porta e staccata vabbè non
importa non interessa ci sono di qua una
fantasia nel appendere i quadri sti qui
ma che poi tra l'altro la gam asti
quadri qui che si mettono sui corridoi
10 successo
jason e lui non è che mi ha accarezzato
diciamo che sta succedendo
dove sono gli anni accoltellato dove mi
ha portato c'è un cellulare che squilla
lo sento che vibrava beh non lo so
ragazzi non sono son finito bene sta
cosa non me l'aspettavo di jason siamo
all'interno perché sono entrati in un
manicomio ragazzi perché avete una
risposta a questo no probabilmente
scritta nelle nei primi gen
quando c'erano le frasi scritte in
portoghese ma non ci ho capito una mazza
quindi non lo so perché c'è un cellulare
chiama casa faticose museo svuoto e xvi
reto esker e dodo mouse para utilizzano
cellular perfetto loro opzioni sa bene
c'è un cellulare a che cosa ci serve a
chiamare questa ma va facciamo luce col
cellulare ci mancherebbe che possiamo
chiamare a casa la produttività di tutto
questo mi lascia sconcertato cos'è m
udeur scomodi impararne ste quarto è une
nahum melem brodin ada che metroc se sei
un truzzo pazzo e vabbè non si capisce
un cazzo va bè ragazzi non sono roba
vera che mi ricorda un coso come si
chiamino mi ricordo il nome
quello dove dicevi il cellulare mio dio
non mi ricordo nome va bè ragazzi sono
vecchio la mia memoria fa cilecca
perfetto
c'è la torta carta bello c'è una sedia
america quando so che cosa sto andando a
fare ma noi andiamo a un'altra porta
aperta perfetto sempre peggio
prima c'era la sedia insanguinato adesso
c'e letto dopo ci trovo una macchina
sicuro non lo so che noi andiamo alla
gente e io secondo voi dove vado parte
di qua non si apre quello sento degli
otto minuti
non so da dove arriva non m'interessa
andiamo avanti
via di qui sorpassiamo st sedia e
sebbene prefetto la ragazzina portiamoci
la segna dietro ben enormi torio
dormitorio di qua per le pay bay quattro
ragazzi quadri sono fantastici bello
sexy
ho sentito il rumore è chiusa è chiusa
con lucchetto benissimo indietro ho
sentito un rumore che non mi è piaciuto
per niente la sedia si è messa su a non
era quella la sedia e prefetto si è
sfondata la porta quella col sangue e te
pareva quale doveva sfondarsi se non
questa permesso
come si è snodato stavolta se non c'è
nessuno è uscito in settimana
cioè non solo se era mai uscito io entro
sarà mica sotto il letto
non lo so c'è una sola chiave ringrazio
iddio c'è un bambino benissimo ragazzi
usciamo di pavia
apriamo lucchetto entriamo qui dentro
bravissimo siamo andati avanti bene chi
è quello perché ci sono delle braccia
che cadono ragazzi ci sono delle braccia
appeso al soffitto non è normale sta
cosa g al cellulare di là ok se ti te io
non ho capito quello e jason comunque
già perché ci sono delle braccia
paranormal sedia
ok bene c'è una sedia che si è passato
da sola ci sono le piacere fa vj sentite
è questa mi sembra molto più techno
dance va bene ragazzi dobbiamo andar via
di qui perché non mi piace nel posto
direi di seguire gesù è la soluzione
migliore alla fine ragazze dobbiamo
andare di qua e attento allo scivolare
jason cioè sei tu jason 360 zio che
voglio totti tiene che c'è gente ha
aperto la porta avanti benissimo ragazzi
stiamo andando più ampia bello sempre
sempre meglio raga sempre meglio questo
mi sembra un carcere più che un
manicomio va beh sono ok ragazzi che bei
rumori che sento fantastico mi
invogliano ad andare avanti io cosa
faccio ci vado ovviamente ci vado
buongiorno
buongiorno a lei
senta c'è jason ma perché sono ragazzi
così bianchi che che che volteggia non
si capisce che schifo perché c'è del 36
o mi dice dove jason levi dal caso
grazie perché non si può andare avanti
così
raga la situazione si sta facendo
pessima buongiorno senta lei è veramente
sexy mimì può dire dove jason o perché
qua la gente non è molto ospitale
almeno lei mi sembra un tipo molto
educato con un cazzo fermo stai fermo
stai fermo ok non se sapevo non ti
chiedevo se ti zio non ti disturbo oltre
ti lascio qui perché ok ok ok se
veramente figo fatto lire ma edizione
sto facendo malissimo bene beh via via
di qua
la tragedia è veramente assurdo comunque
come gioco ve lo dico perché mette un
asse incredibile ed redoubt i videogame
call o col cellulare che non mi
ricordavo il nome sei veramente un figo
fattelo dire se in una posizione anche
tu guarda che 7
vabbè sentitevi farei una foto vita ieri
su facebook
raga è un'impresa impossibile ma ci
posso provare by voi poi ok perfetto
quello non mi ha visto questo è troppo
avanti
aiuta questo è sexy questo è ancora di
sexy posso fare corri ho perso 25 punti
vita ma non importa me ne rimangono
altri 25 la parola posso minchia che gli
occhi
raga veramente stesse i quadri
in un istituto sanitaria sono la cosa
migliore che potessero fare
vabbè raga io sono sempre con te sempre
fottuti corridoi ma questo non era
quello di prima perché c'è un braccio
perché esce un braccio da uno scatolone
perché chi è che ha fatto un trasloco
frankestein vabbè c'è c'è un altro
braccio perfetto ragazzi ci sono braccia
voi non fateci caso l'unica [ __ ]
cos'era cos'è successo essere una porta
bene è sempre se per questa la porta che
si sfonda perfetto ok bene mi sto
portando via la porta perfetto ragazzi
c'è un tipo molto più nemmeno c'era
almeno c'è una cosa sono è un
antipsicotico ragazzi
prendiamoci sto anche la cosa fare
aumentare la vita perfetto
intanto la porta si è messa di lato da
sola non vogliono anche sapere come non
voglio voglio finire che sto maledetto
gioco perché non jason centro sei tu
jason senti jason è successo un casino
aiutami tu ti prego perché qua c'è gente
brutta molto sexy e molto sexy questo lo
devo dire però è veramente brutta nel
complesso va bene ragazzi jason
ci sono due sempre le calze andato cesso
c'è un buco nel terreno raga dobbiamo
infilarci qui dentro per forza lara gut
3 21 tuf l'olimpionico ok non solo siamo
finiti ma io mi sarei mai buttato in un
buco dove ci sia infilato anche jason
mar tra l'altro non lo so rumor che nei
team per 24 ore messaggi gratis ok
chioda delle sedie su soffritto non lo
del giorno leggendo nel centro che si
sta producendo perché gli ha appiccicato
delle sedie sul soffitto per che l'anci
le sedie
dimmelo 66 me avevi fame magari ti
faccio un tramezzino non so mangiamo
insieme dimmelo non lo so raga siamo
immensa che cosa ci facciamo immensa
sentite io non so dov'è andato jason ma
vado di qua perché l'unica porta aperta
perché sto mongolo bello veramente figo
ragazzino cosa molto molto molto sexy
arrapante giuro non so dove sono jason
basta col ti prego ti sto seguendo da
un'ora e mezza affermati un [ __ ]
secondo ok qualcosa mi dice che io non
ci debba più andare lì infatti non ci
vado
jason si sono fati jason jason che cazz
sul senso a pregio sarebbe martello e
chiave inglese sarebbero attrezzi che
bello che sei no veramente figo ragazzi
fa piacere che sia stato così gentile da
darmeli senza opporre resistenza e
quindi parliamo indietro è perché è
diventato tutto buio si è spenta poi
ragazzo che cazzo aiuto anche se ho
sentito la voce bluetooth perfetto
ragazzi è spenta na cosa è successo
cos'è successo
dove è finito il mouse era lo persol
avevo perso ma l'ho ritrovato bene mi
sono caricato 8 pozzo ok ho fatto anche
malissimo alla gamba perché ho sbattuto
contro la scrivania non importa ok
torniamo indietro e anche veloci oddio
chi è questo cos'è cos'è sta roba via
corri corri corri chiuderà ragazzi c'è
qualcuno qui c'è tanto lo sento sempre
sotto subito
eccolo il mio dio tutti ragazzi è bene
ca4 braccio che mi escono dia di cui via
di qui via e sfondato asta porta non è
più chiusa non mi serve la chiave ti
prego qualsiasi cosa sono sti quadri non
mi aprì dei ragazzi è una cosa assurda è
una cosa assurda sto maledettissimo
gioco siamo veramente ragazzi vi voglio
bene quando vi consiglia di queste cose
ti voglio bene vi giuro non so contro
perso di vita guardi ce ne sono visti
affari
io vado di qui vado di qua caldi giuro
che preferivo jason a tutto sto casino
preferivo molto molto di più jason a sta
gente
comunque ho fatto sei vivo
ok devo andare di qua dentro raga io non
voglio neanche spiegazioni falso gioco
non le chiedo basta che lo finisco in
fretta
vabbè andiamo c'è un rapporto semi
aperta di non ci vorrei entrare ma
centro perfetto
cosa ci devo fare qui
ringraziando iddio si è accesa la
ragazzi ho riacceso le luci grazie mille
e sono spa è giustamente quando si
accendono le luci non c'è più nessuno
così faccio la figura del deficiente no
veramente non ce la facevo più
era troppo buio cosa devo fare per avere
perché c'è un simbolo rosso ad ottenere
mento che ne so io come così vai così
raga io vi giuro che sto sudan
a parte la il caldo ma sto sudando farlo
perché mi sto pagando addosso perché ci
sono braccio a quella l'uscita quella e
l'uscita quella el'us jason non romperle
palle gol di el uscita
voglio uscire di qua usciamo tutta
precisamente la fisica mentre c'erano i
quadri prima adesso non ci sono più
fammi uscire e jazz bravo non ci sei più
bravo sì siamo il city non si voglio che
la mia con la macchina via via
assolutamente via come c entra in
macchina maledizione come centro
a c.so le chiavi bene perfetto apri apri
apri abbiamo visti la macchina
ragazza c'era un mucchietto penso che la
chiave serva ad aprire la porta qui
non lo so ragazzi non lo so si sia
aperta st porta ragazze e roero fuori
c'era gamma vi rendete conto che ero
fuori perché devo allora sei stato tanto
deficiente da entrare in un manicomio
abbandonato sei uscito rientri c'è ma
scherziamo ma cosa ma perché piangi che
piango di più i ragazzi è brutta la
situazione era avanti
ok beh avevo detto vai orgia ho cercato
di essere cortese va beh
apro io a sto punto non ti cazzare però
chi sei tu chi sei
va bene non cosa perché sia massei cinco
anos de mi vida tentando di incontrare
un colpa genoma è finito così sono
riuscito a entrare in rapporto a trovare
un tizio che non so chi sia e poi vabbè
io non ho parole non so leggere perché
tanto non capisco una mazza
la chiudo più perché non non ne posso
più vi giuro sei video è piaciuto
lasciato il commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione senso di siti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo nel
prossimo vito bene ragazzi